all right my name is Sully I'm a
software engineer at Google and today I
have here with me Janet Janet is the
co-chair of the kubernetes coupon for
Seattle this year as well as for China
yeah so Janet how did you get involved
with let's start with kubernetes how did
you get involved with kubernetes project
to begin with so I started with my first
project at Google so in the beginning I
was interviewing at a bunch of places
and then I got a phone call from Google
and it's Tim Hawking he's a principal
software engineer at Google and I had a
brief conversation with him and he just
told me how great kubernetes is and it's
going to change the world and it's still
very very new at that time so I just say
I just think I I decided to jump in the
ship and go with the kubernetes team
that's awesome and how long ago was that
and it's three years ago three years
Congrats so since then you've been a
avid contributor in the kubernetes
community what are some of the things
that you've contributed to in over the
last three years so I mean applications
special interest group so we mainly
focusing on kubernetes applications and
your experience in your experience
running corporate applications in
kubernetes so the workflows API and like
deployment API that most people are
using and the stateful side demon side
and jobs con jobs those of those kind of
stuffs and recently I was working on
improving the garbage collection of
resources because I observed that a lot
of users have resources in their
clusters but they cannot clean them up
very easily so I want to improve that
part as well that sounds awesome so it
sounds like recently you switch gears a
little bit and are taking on the task of
leading putting together Q Khan which
this one is 8,000 attendees what is that
like how did you get involved
and what can you tell us about that so a
lot of people ask me the same question
about how I get and how do they how can
they sign up but actually I didn't sign
up and I just got an email from Dan Kahn
he's the executive of CNCs he just asked
me hey Janet would you like to be the
co-chair of Q Khan and I it was like oh
my god of course yes
it is awesome yeah were you hesitant at
all or did you have any concerns going
in or were you just excited i I'm just
too excited and then later I figure out
oh there's a lot of things going on
there a lot of a lot of things that you
need to do that normal attendees
wouldn't know there's a lot of work
there and so can you talk about some of
that what are the some of the things
that our audience might not know about
that goes into putting together an event
like this so first we need to review all
the CFP s so CFP is like a proposal for
your talk so we need to review all of
them and pick the ones that we think
that the community can most benefit from
and also we'll take some of the talks as
a keynote speeches and also will invite
some industry leaders to give keynotes
if we think they'll bring some new ideas
to us and then cultures need to do also
do MC and we also have a chance to do
our own keynotes and that's a you gave
your first keynote this morning right
sorry okay tomorrow yeah that would be
tomorrow and on Thursday that's super
exciting I are you ready to be in front
of the audience of 8,000 people yeah
that's super cool so what are some of
the things that you know didn't quite go
as expected that maybe you would suggest
improvements on in the future
for a coupon event-planning any of that
so for example I did the co-chair for
both Shanghai and Seattle and at the
time because Shanghai is the first one
in Asia so we did a bit of experiment
for example we try to have people submit
to both conferences at once but then
later we figure that caused some
confusion to people so we are not going
to do that next year so if you want to
submit a PU submit to each conference
individually got it that's super cool
and so outside of Q con what are you
looking forward to in the next year in
the kubernetes community or anything at
large so I think service and service
match is taking off and a lot of people
are building applications of kubernetes
they are writing their on operators to
operate their own applications and also
people are building developer tools for
you to easily create your your operators
and things like that so I'm very excited
about how people you know build on top
of kubernetes make it easier to deploy
applications yeah exactly
well that sounds awesome thank you very
much for your time Janet and have a
great rest of your coupon here this is a
great event thank you thank you all
right take care
[Music]